you just brought it up man obviously
your mom
killed your dad yeah you know like how
did how did you did you know that since
you were a little kid no so how i found
out me and my brother i told you we had
different dads so when i'm about 13 he
went to his dad's for the weekend
and came back
after the weekend trip with his dad and
we were like fighting
and i had him pinned down
you know i was bodying him and he was
like that's why mom killed your dad and
i'm like huh
what and i got up i was i let him go i
went to i was like mom what is he
talking about and my mom's face just
turned like
her black face turned white as white as
snow and i was like oh
oh this is real okay
and you know she gave me some story then
but after that was the day that i lost
respect for authority like complete
respect for authority i felt like all
adults lie
um you know i have no trust i can't
trust anybody
you know i mean so then it was like
nobody could tell me nothing that was
like that was the day that like
shifted you know for me yeah like i
wouldn't listen to the teachers
principals anybody an authority figure
cops nobody what about your mom did you
did your relationship with your mama
it's like literally it's taken until
like you know the last couple years like
to be
post me right in the book i was like i
got everything out and you know i think
for all of my life i was just wanting
her to say sorry and she never did
yeah it was always like you know some
kind of excuses do you think do you
think she knows how to say sorry because
this is the she just did yeah she just
did finally she just called me one day i
don't know what was about three months
ago four months ago and she just said
son
i'm sorry
and i was like what
i'm 38 years old
wow and you and i and i without even
getting deeper i just said i've been
waiting for that for a long time i
appreciate it yeah that's it you know
what i mean and we move on from there
it's kind of like we're talking about
yesterday mike how
you know hurt people hurt people
sometimes you know
sometimes sometimes from just being
honest dude from wanting the good for
somebody else we tend to hurt them more
because
you know what i'm saying we weren't real
with them
right you know what i'm saying right
right i'm sure your mom didn't you know
obviously i mean that's that's that's so
personal you know what i mean right and
you know it's like
you want people when you when you say
sorry to somebody you want them to
forgive you and not hold it over your
head you know what i mean because
you're hoping but that's not just not
everybody has to be there but it doesn't
have to be that way it depends on what
you did depending on how sensitive they
were to
the subject right so when i say i'm
sorry when i'm saying i'm sorry i'm
hoping they like you kill somebody yet
no
yeah it'd be all right
right when facebook so when she said
sorry i had to really before i said it's
all good know that it was all good yeah
yeah you had a you let go of like your
she's like you're you're you know the
weight you know what i'm saying right
yeah you don't want to be alive no more
you listen i'm starting being like i
like so much to see i told the truth by
accident
stop [ __ ] lying
everything everything anything just
tells them
and now they know what they have exactly
now it's up to them to make the decision
they're gonna keep this or not you might
have nine lives bro yeah i do have nine
lives